five things Coffee Park bakery viewpoint
and water I'm in Oslo and I'm tired it's
[Music]
4:00 in the morning in DC right now I
haven't slept
my body is begging me to just go to
sleep right now but I know from
experience that that never ends well I
promise it never ends well over the
years of dealing with jet lag there are
five things that I find are a great way
to curb the jet lag and see the city all
in one so let's get started
wait actually no I have to get a haircut
first because I'm just I'm feeling a
little and I'm speaking at City Hall
tonight in Oslo where they give up a
Nobel Peace Prize like that same venue
and I can look like this weird haircut
but that's not one of the five things
that's just that's just my thing don't
show up to new city and get a haircut
okay I don't care the training yes yeah
[Music]
where they give up a Nobel Peace Prize
like that same venue the trainee did a
great job and I got 50% off my haircut
okay let's get to these five things
first
a latte please right here that was a
wonderful latte
thank you so much yes have a great day
bye-bye
yes nothing better than a quality latte
all day oh and fun fact I guess I can't
help myself
Norway drinks more coffee than any other
country in the world per capita next up
is water not every city has a waterfront
but most cities do there's usually a
river and along that river there is
usually a nice walk it's a good way to
get your bearings because a river or a
body of water doesn't have any buildings
and so you kind of see a more wide open
area and water
don't just energizes me it's that weird
yeah that's kind of weird the water
energizes me like looking at water
energizes me the best antidote to jet
lag is
not caffeine its movement look at that
shadow isn't sunset no it's literally
noon it's 12:30 1:00 it is noon but the
Sun is in eternal Twilight mode here in
the northern part of our planet during
the winter the Sun doesn't really ever
go above there just kind of that's High
Noon which is amazing if you're a
photographer look at how long that
shadow is so next up the bakery by a
bakery only because it's a bakery it's
like a institution in every country in
the world the bakery is where on display
you can see what the local to bear is
with the foundational steeple of a
places construction there's a guy over
here using a jackhammer
if this were my country the jackhammer
would be 800 times louder
but instead in true Norwegian fashion
it's an electric-powered one and that's
much quieter probably more efficient
probably better for the environment man
I love it here sweet bread he's still
here it's an egg-based yeah I'll try
that is it oh it's coconut on top
cool yeah let's do that it's like oh you
get out of here just pigeon fest I have
some very predatory pigeons so yet bread
it's like carbs it's like comfort it's
all these things that you kind of need
on a jet lag day and it's the sweet
thing that I've never seen before this
is some sort of egg tart with coconut on
it they said it was very Norwegian okay
hmm whoa yeah a licorice in there maybe
some cardamom dude I'm into that it's
like a sweet bagel with creamy egg
goodness on the inside next up let's go
find a viewpoint the reason I like the
viewpoints is because it usually entails
a little bit of a hike which is good for
moving the blood getting your legs worn
out and like the waterfront it is a good
way to get context of the city you've
just landed in you don't have to hit the
most special viewpoint in the city just
hit a viewpoint something that gives you
context of where you are and something
that entails a little bit of a hike like
this hill here we go
[Music]
and I think I'm gonna get a pretty cool
view I mean look at this intense wall
I'm feeling invigorated man that's the
other thing about this whole thing like
you go around searching for all of these
things and it's like it turns into a
little scavenger hunt I'm getting to the
top here shadows you guys are like I
don't care about your shadow like stop
talking about the light I often get
comments when I'm in places with non
photographers they're like dude why do
you keep talking about the light like
it's just licensed the Sun and I'm like
nose looks so nice right now and they're
like you're not even photographing
anything and I'm like I know but it's
like so nice so I'll just stop talking
about my shadow go find a park I don't
try to pack any of like the coolest or
best things in on that first day because
you're just not gonna enjoy it as much
and so just like take the pressure off
your expectations are probably really
high already and just like go on your
little scavenger hunt why a park well
again a part gives you an opportunity to
move to walk around to explore I also
find a part like the beating heart of a
lot of cities it's fun to walk around a
park and just see what's going on are
there local musicians like what cultural
expressions are happening in the park
what's the natural beauty in the park
there's a nice big Central Park here in
Oslo but it's now the holiday season and
so the park has been turned into a fair
of sorts adds extra bonus because now
it's just full of Christmas cheer
[Music]
there you have it or five things I'm
feeling really good coffee
park bakery viewpoint water if you make
the effort to do these five things or
something like them on your first day
take the pressure off and do the big
touristy things you will not regret it
you'll sleep better you'll act the maid
and you'll get to know the city a little
bit better oh and you can get a haircut
if you really want to just make sure to
ask for the trainee
[Music]